Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No giant robots!
The Foundation has been required to use some
seemingly unusual methods of containing anomalies
over the years.
The Polymorphic Humanoid is kept in her containment
by a collection of dogs, for example.
There have been sugar substitutes, vats of
acid, VHS players, and more.
But one thing is certain: we will never employ
the use of giant robots, no matter how many
times Dr. Bright tells everyone to watch Pacific
Rim or any other piece of media that features
them.
We do not trust Dr. Bright with giant robot
technology, nor is it considered the most
efficient use of Foundation resources.
No, Dr. Bright, not even on your birthday.
Okay…
Except the Dragon Slayer.